shot by morris with no cousin right now  to help space the floor bring some  energy where is this team going to get  buckets from they have to do it  in the full court getting some turnovers  and getting some easy looks  okay just joining us kuzma out left calf  injury  as a chua gets it deep and is fouled  he's calling for a goaltend here does he  play for miami  he might not be playing but he's easy to  find on the bench let's put it that way  he's got the  he's rocking the heat colors man he's  looking very miami tonight  that's a good look see kuzma can pull  that off oh yeah he could pull it off i  still have you know got to get a little  used to it i'm sure when he saw it he  said  oh okay